believe it or not a clock on your head
beats at a different rate than a clock
on your foot we can now measure this and
it has practical importance as well
first of all I'm Stan said that time is
a river so gigantic river we're all
swept up in the river of time and it can
speed up and it slows down for example
on the moon did you know that time beats
faster on the moon than it does on the
earth and we can measure this on Jupiter
time beats slower on Jupiter than it
does on the earth so time beats at
different rates when an object moves
very fast time slows down inside that
rocket that is moving very fast if that
rocket is then placed on the moon time
beats faster so we have two competing
effects this has a direct implication
with regards to your cell phone your
cell phone has GPS which allows you to
locate objects on the planet Earth by
focusing in on satellites orbiting the
planet earth satellites travel at 18,000
miles per hour if they're in low-earth
orbit therefore time slows down for
those low-lying satellites but if
satellites go farther and farther away
gravity gets less and less and less so
time speeds up so we're not a space we
have two competing effects fast
satellites slow down in time very far
away satellites slow speed up in time
and in fact at one radius you can
calculate time beats exactly the same
rate as it does on the planet Earth so
what does it mean your GPS system would
totally fail without Einstein's theory
of special and general relativity this
also means that the top of your head
because it is farther from the center of
the earth beats at a faster rate time
beats at a faster rate than your feet so
you can actually show that even within
your own body now our instruments are so
accurate that you could show within your
own body the fact that time beats at
different rates within your own body
you